[Music]
Jason Statham and Rosie
huntington-whiteley are balancing
parenthood too but they left 13 month
old Jack at home for daddy's big
Hollywood premiere a stunning fiance and
baby mama fans swarming you and one of
the most iconic action stars on hand
think Jason's made it I don't know I
might faint slower I know really well
and it's great to be able to call him a
friend he was he's been you know as a
childhood hero mine
he looks Eroica negative attitude
Jason's movie is the meg short for
Megalodon that's a giant prehistoric
shark thought to be extinct well it's
not in state them must save the day he
did his own underwater stunts with 25
bull sharks those are the ones more
dangerous than great whites and you nope
no cage you don't know how aggressive
they're gonna be and there's always an
element of surprise with a wild animal
you know it's they're unpredictable and
so the nerves come from the unknown oh
but this 51 year old has experience in
the water
England's jason statham check him out in
a speedo diving in the 1990 Commonwealth
Games in New Zealand that's where he got
to train for this move it was in the
same country
Jason went from diving to modeling in
the 90s and even had some risk a music
video cameos his co-stars aren't jealous
at all I was on my high school chess
team so suck it Statham he actually went
to three Olympics as a diver he's pretty
good such an underachiever
you